foreign
[Music]
you don't like our youth what's wrong
with them
nothing we'll find out also when I mean
them I don't mean them as a group I'm
using their proper pronouns
there you go you found it
I'm Nina I'm Grace I'm Jocelyn
I think I'm like the shy one like I I
balanced them out I would definitely say
I'm the wild one they're pretty crazy
open relationship
oh let's say open titties because that
corset is wild my what might die
yeah yeah congratulations on that I
said that yeah my die what does that
mean don't ask no question
you know when you're wrong you're right
that's how you be a man
thank you photography I've been uh just
got a film camera I love biking I'm
really into music and I like acting
sorry
I snowboard and rock climbed
yeah
you didn't hear that I snowboard
and rock climbed
all right has everybody here been with
the woman of color before
of course yes
I haven't been in relationships
what does everybody think about therapy
and are you in therapy no I'm an
advocate I use some online one to better
help one okay
cool because they brought up like deep
stuff from like my channel
[Music]
every week every week okay okay
everybody needs it you know what I mean
yeah to some degree I tried to schedule
an appointment and they didn't reply
at least you're trying I've never been
to therapy but everybody's got their
type of therapy my type of therapy is
nature kind of thing like going Outdoors
do you plan on ever going to therapy if
it if I need it yeah I'm not against it
but
where I've been and where I'm at I
haven't had it haven't needed it yeah
okay what are some red flags you guys
stay away from you didn't go to therapy
they say that I'll lose it no I
actually lose it I actually lose it but
I'm gonna keep my money I'm not going to
feed it I don't like when someone's too
clingy I think we need like a life
outside of each other what's one word
you guys would use to describe
yourselves they're passionate
yeah I'd say swagalicious
I think they're going to eliminate
swagalicious that's my suspicion you
think they're going to eliminate swag
Alicia I think so
what's the name of person standing next
to you the puzzle yeah I like the games
Nick Nick yeah it's an advocate for
therapy
I feel bad
I think my friend
I was gonna say yeah I was thinking
because it was like yeah and then the
therapy question I think everybody needs
it yeah
what's wrong
everyone needs therapy what's your
definition of therapy hold up let's be
clear they already did find it because
he said my former therapy is going out
to Nature and doing Hobbies so clearly
he has outlets they don't recognize that
as well at their time so what they're
talking about is one thing cool
seeing a psychologist
I yeah yeah that's what they're talking
about talking about so we're going off
that yeah everyone needs that apparently
I see what you're saying I think that
everybody needs therapy
well you mean therapy differently yes
there you go and that's not what they
mean but it's not terrible right so I
agree with you there you don't need
Alice so nobody's gonna say people don't
need Hobbies people need things they
need to do in life to unleash whatever
it is okay
they're talking about therapy with a
I have a personal problem with this
because one it seems as though the only
way to unravel or to help or to heal or
to improve on your mental state for them
is through therapy right and this is
like the trend I've seen over the last
seven or eight years is that one people
start assuming a whole bunch of mental
sicknesses that they don't actually have
people you know like this is a problem
even the medical field people start
going to the doctor too much and they're
actually the ones who cause the most
amount of burdens on the Health Care
system because they go there for
everything and anything whereas there's
a group of people who don't go there at
all these people what they're saying is
everyone needs therapy you all need
something there's something wrong with
you that you cannot heal through any
other means or methods I hate this kind
of messaging we basically told young
people to pathologize themselves their
own issues and always turn it into some
kind of condition oh I have BPD why
because sometimes I get angry and then
other times you're a human okay
you don't have BPD a lot of people are
just self-diagnosing because it's like
the new thing that's in on these social
media apps and this is another
reflection of that who are you to look
at somebody who says I'm good and you're
like no you need therapy
who are we
I'm just saying whenever I hear this
kind of lingo it just it really rubs me
the wrong way oh yeah you need some
healing you need to go to for what
reason what have you even seen their
behavior
just because you're up don't mean
you got to project that on everybody
else that's your problems and just
because you need a doctor to talk to you
doesn't mean everyone else does let's
also be honest
therapy is a privilege
yup definitely
forget being able to even afford one
affording one doesn't even have the
problem
you have to afford 10 because best
believe you're gonna have to shop for a
good therapist and one is not gonna get
you out
you're hitting a lottery if you find the
right therapist on the first try so nah
not everybody needs therapy but
just notice something I really
appreciate the people who talk like this
and say this kind of goofy stuff always
look weird like this anything you want
to say on the therapy top no no that's
what I said I mean even when you see a
therapist seeing a therapist won't heal
you you know what the therapist
generally does it helps you either
unravel some things in your mind or
point you in some actionable steps that
you can start to take in your own life
but if you're already taking those
actionable steps you don't need them you
know sometimes you see a therapist it'll
say well do you have any hobbies do you
have any kind of physical Outlets do you
have people you can talk to in your life
do you have a support system do you have
a job that gives you some kind of
rewarding feeling but if you're already
taking those actionable steps why do you
need the therapy for yeah okay
um Nicholas no but he was so sweet but I
don't think it's us we're like very
strong personalities and I just
do we agree on him I feel like
Capricorns are generally very material
driven really you guys can be pretty
stubborn nah I don't think so okay yeah
I mean I think it's the personality I
agree yeah I'm sure you're much more
multifaceted than that you said you're
in therapy and therapy inner child work
no bro this cringe that's uh uh
something is like very disturbing first
off she's like Capricorns are this so
like she starts assuming all kinds of
things about his mental state and the
kind of personalities has then she
pretends to be some kind of open-minded
weirdo who's just like oh yeah but it's
so great that you're healing yourself
through therapy it's like you
marginalized him of one hand with this
whole about sometimes
at the same time you want to pretend
like you open-minded because you're like
therapy is amazing it's like get the
out of here I don't know I just my
life experience is the people who do
this whole empathy empathy are
like some of the most closed-minded I
just I I don't know it always rubs me
the wrong way but this is my bicy so
don't listen to me wait what do you do
besides climbing for fun I like to do
yoga I like to journal fashion stuff
thrifting journaling is cool I started
doing that it's like super like I guess
therapeutic yeah it is but I'd be
talking crazy about people I'm sorry is
this it's coming out a lot
it's coming out a lot
but let's keep watching I'm gonna keep
my mouth shut I have a question for you
actually okay okay so when it comes to
yourself right what is your favorite
thing about yourself emotionally I think
I'm really like adaptive I can relate to
other people really well like if you're
high energy I'll be high energy if
you're a little low I'll be the high
energy for you yeah exactly cool all
right about what a that thing is if
you're a high energy I can be high
energy and if you can if you're lower
energy
I can be your high energy
[Laughter]
like I can adapt this dish for you you
know if you like spicy food I can make
it spicy and if you don't like spicy
food you I could do it spicy and you can
just put it on the side
do you miss the Portland weather at all
yeah actually yeah it's surprising right
New York and Portland both have a big
Jazz scene oh and I'm in the Jazz okay
so I've never been to New York but I
really want to yeah okay so I know you
said you were interested in music when
you're saying your passion so it's jazz
music something that you're passionate
about it is yeah yeah I was in jazz band
uh from middle school all the way
through high school yeah jazz is it's
not like a big part of what the is
wrong with the music for real I don't
know I understand what you're trying to
do because they're talking about jobs
Bob
when I'm having a conversation what the
is this what the
is this I'm trying to do it
[Laughter]
what the is going on man
Nick had such a good like fluid and like
conversation he's a great
conversationalist very great eye contact
I love talking to him and so I chose
Noah can you I chose Nick I wrote Nicki
poo I chose Nick also the ladies love me
so I chose Jayden
[Music]
hey bro listen you didn't do anything
wrong
[Music]
you know the best part
look at the Heights
a lot of short guys are just going off
like oh man my final decision ended
up being
rich
I really loved the conversation and I
thought they have a lot of comments feel
sick so I chose yourself
they put crickets I told you she
wasn't feeling them no she was there she
wasn't I told you she wasn't I think it
flowed I think there's a lot in common
um I chose Mina yeah yeah all the this I
went on all you guys are lovely I had a
great time with each and every one of
you
damn
I mean the girls are already picked the
two black people didn't get any the two
black people didn't get me the person
that I chose
is it was hard I'm gonna be honest I'm
still complaining even right now hey
just saying hey this guy you know what
it is about this dude it's a bit too
politically correct for me you know what
I'm saying just say it I'm sure you got
some skeletons in your closet you don't
have to pretend to be the best part of
the world to be a piece of in this
woman say I got a thousand dollars he's
changing choose an Asian lady
are you high yeah ah the girl that I
chose was
really cool
black people gets no love
[Music]
people are not happy about the therapy
stuff either no that's what they're
saying I I don't like yeah that's
actually a great comment somebody said
I'm a strong advocate for therapy and
destigmatizing it still don't believe
that everyone must use it but everyone
can benefit from it so it should be
easily accessible to all they're still
very young and are in a group of
like-minded girls who seem to agree on
almost everything there's no one to play
Devil's Advocate on the subject and
challenge them to expand their views
that breeds a little bit
of ignorance sometimes
a lot of people have healthy Outlets
that don't currently need therapy
there you go
that's a great comment right there that
is true that they just seem to agree on
everything and then just backing each
other up but uh both therapy thing I
think is probably the most interesting
part of this for me obviously we had
some other laps but yeah if you're
sitting at home and you're struggling
with certain things it doesn't
necessarily mean that you need therapy
sometimes you got to go through the
steps of life to figure things out
yourself but sometimes therapy can also
be a good tool just understand
therapy is not the end it'll be all a
lot of times you need a bit better
finding some good physical and artistic
Outlets having a good support system
people you can talk to in your personal
life those will always be much better
substitutes for therapy so just
understand there's actionable steps you
can take to improve your mental and your
physical health that don't require you
going to see a shrink okay
doesn't mean it's wrong to I'm saying
you don't need to because I this message
is really important because for people
who can't afford it we shouldn't be
convincing them that if they need
therapy because they can't afford it
their food think about what kind of
message that sense
a lot of people can't afford therapy so
when you're saying everyone needs it and
a lot of people can't get it you're
saying they're is that a good
message and there's people all over the
world who function amazingly well in
poor countries and other places and have
zero access to therapy so don't make it
out to be something that's absolutely
necessary I think it's a poor way to
engage with the topic
um and I'm somebody who advocates for it
I just don't like the way a lot of young
people are doing it or the way a lot of
people are jumping on Mental Health
in general they just want to have maybe
they want to be able to put a Medicaid
don't want to be able to put a tag on
everything like that it was a little tag
all I usually whatever I think it's two
degrees separated from it's not
up I think therapy and mental health
stuff is two degrees separated from
astrology
the way they treat about it that the way
they go with it yes if you notice the
people talk about mental health and a
lot of astrology stuff vast majority of
them are wood yeah Okay the reason why I
think women like a lot of astrology
stuff is sometimes it helps them make
sense of the world yeah yeah I feel like
they know a little bit Yeah closure and
no one and over men do conspiracy
theories women do astrology okay
to be honest with therapy is oftentimes
just another part of that it's like
you're seeing Behavior you don't totally
understand it oh that person they're a
narcissist oh that person has bipolar
disorder oh that person has split
personality whatever it is they just
throw it on the same way they're like
they're Capricorn that's how they act
Tauruses right to me the way they true
it and it's unfortunate because everyone
knows astrology is or most
people don't take it seriously from an
academic standpoint but therapy and
mental health related issues are very
real there's people suffering from it so
when people use this kind of lingo very
nearly and just throw it out for no
reason it has real ramifications
and I think it also makes people take it
less seriously over time I think that
it's like and how men and women are yeah
men want to not know something and
dismiss it because they're not
interested and women want to be able to
dismiss it because they think they know
so the astrology and stuff like that oh
I know what this is dismissed oh I know
what this is
where man is like I'm not interested
that shit's crazy to me
dismissed but whatever I'd have to dig
more into that maybe maybe I was just
gonna say I feel like men do like they
want to know or feel like they know
something because I see conspiracy
theories all the time that they can yeah
and that's their own version of that
sure but I'm not mad at the theory all
right let us know what you guys think in
the comments below do you guys agree or
disagree want to hear from you